[ __ ] I hate wasting time hate wasting
time
what's up snapchat so I'm here to watch
the Jets loss again with that I think
I'll go down to 73 pounds per year what
do you play enough like me
no one
gary vaynerchuk how are you well thank
you I appreciate it
hope you have a great weekend this has
just been the narrative of my life you
know like like whether it was email
marketing when I had 90 percent open
rates in 96 or Google AdWords when I was
five cents a click or starting YouTube
show and within the year of YouTube
launching or being one of the first
personalities on Twitter this is all it
is it's just when is when is it a year
before everybody else is going to be
there or eighteen months before
everybody else is going to be there
that's what I like to strike not two
years not three years I've been writing
about snapchat winning for three years I
invested in it well over a year ago like
I believed in this platform a long time
the reason I Gary the brand now I'm
getting loud is the moment is upon us
they're here
that was son
crickets Gary Vaynerchuk how are you
super well I have my calendar that we're
recording today I'm at the door do you
that's in your first dramedy Rock [ __ ]
man and you can keep the [ __ ] the video
what's up is that I'm here to record the
book and I just called the guy and he
said nope it's Thursday and Friday and
when I look at my calendar and button in
my calendar post I do see that so I'm
coming I'm coming to the office figure
out that [ __ ] is going on
[ __ ]
I hate wasting time hey mister
what's up snapchat so I'm here to record
my audio book and there's a mix-up and I
[ __ ] Annie mix-ups so not be
recording today
wait
just like you answers for yourself
oh hey Garrett I just texted you I
texted you a square root for Instagram
and and long for Twitter wasn't sure
which one is yours we saw how we go with
getting contracts under 2016
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 174 of the askgaryvee
show
a little salty I'm supposed to be
recording my audio book right now there
was some calendar mix-up not sure having
gotten to the bottom of it put on here
it was a good actions honorable shooter
what something's acting really the first
time in he remembers well is that even
is that even been up is that new just
like doing that yeah the one that you
want yeah let me double yeah you get two
for one school you know sing handle
helps you know yeah I think it's cooking
hey all right
good has got my girl pleasure no thanks
pretty good how are you good man
so we filter the kid a levy we are okay
might make a cameo in daily me so tell
myself hey guys John Linux I just had my
little meeting with Gary and he's just
so far word thinking and he really cares
about the employees to set up these
one-on-one meetings and just like get a
little taste of what you feel for the
company and I'm I've just been having a
great time I really appreciate the time
he sets aside for all of us it's awesome
thanks man I really appreciate it glad
you're here yeah
good luck to success blossom every day
thank you so much thank you Lena
it's me it nice to meet you or things
pretty good cold oh sorry I'm stuffy
no worries so you that was your weekend
just battling the elements
I'm like super all this is my schedule
sighs miss else wasn't you could update
everything we're fine just FYI you're
gonna go to the Knicks game with Wayne
on the 2nd February okay
I just did something your ass before he
got back free hello hello why do you
color I was an actress
three weeks you retain it pretty well
you Vegas for a week the other that was
indoors the whole time cool chicken I
basically just want to lock down roles
responsibilities for landlords
Department and then get confirmation on
what this means super quick we're
jumping to me you they they're being
social you tear like Oh Stephanie uh
you're not on the event I'm coming I
just want be up social to be best in
class why am I not in this one I think
it was just every day we were we were
chatting about any time in our chest I
think I'm gonna jump into right now is
that what's going on yeah it is hogsback
thank you
drinka why'd you up like that I won't
play the room these type of things were
expected baby please I need a sleeve I
don't like to be unprotected I've seen
these types of germs get neglected I'm
getting money now I told you when the
kids were on the bed and we were
sleeping on a little couch only had a
little cloud so you tell if you want to
be Wi-Fi leadership from the agency to
dovetail with your own
now cuz I just need to control it just
don't know like like maybe but maybe
after all hands on I don't know I don't
see us putting stakes in the ground in
our POV store soldier
what about responding fans that are
happening out in the world intelligently
that speaks to the philosophy we have
that's why I happened like this like
this is just the first kickoff it's why
I have to really think about it good to
get cancelled yes that's good because
that was I thought I was [ __ ] a son
yes it did that it does but it's cool Oh
see guys things happen for a reason are
you willing to go ahead family yes they
got to know that my daughter Cubs horse
of course that I want to be there but
you know this is the one thing that I
want to move for it
okay cool then we are home okay
on the camera-ready super plus get that
in there hello so mother I love her and
her daughter how you doing great good
good good
yeah so I'll make everything right for
you bro we have plenty of time okay
it's should be Chad and March yeah I
think we should great fine thank you
you're welcome
thanks here Julie you soon see you soon
you back that you can keep why do you
not do you want to like straight up chug
that what are you trying to make some
snapchat Kanta yeah but it I mean I also
want you to drink the water at sunlight
guys this is Mike trying to gain me by
chugging this water for his snapchat
purposes Mike do you even care about my
health or is just about your snapchat
Channel I care about your health
thank you what about me Sarah
what about my snapping frankly you're
really behind the ball on getting your
story [ __ ] together both I think frankly
like finding any job is tough and this
little surprise that's not what are you
talking about
why ball on the weekends up you actually
that's wrong weekends I'm like I'm
printable at least you're not just doing
like the up your nostril shot anymore
that's true
good point sir thanks for the words of
encouragement they learned all thank you
can you Kela HR know that I want to
personally do your review I would love
that absolutely you got it sister
also I think I'm really good at snapchat
actually alright find you rock thrower
snapchat handle on you all right sorry
yes Mike Reid each other let's go
when no one's watching guys
even garyvee chunks is water I don't
jump by what I'm doing this for Mike hey
winner over there
all right shroom Caesars el truco to get
out of here this guy hey you like
drinking water love what do you want to
do more meetings in New Jersey for my
question is there's a 440 flight from
Newark that you could take my brother
fish stuff in Jersey if I can if I can
what about Dennis
yeah yep internet us courtside tickets
to the next nomination I'm a few people
ask that the way you worded your your
Instagram it was looks like I gave you a
gift of it always goes yeah at least
like did you give to make that sauce way
down exactly take that how are you I'll
see that yeah
okay okay no worries go on the account
sign simple them it's like an up staff
chatting I want to make sure you you
like that I'm sorry yeah it's [ __ ] our
yep
I do not leave definitely I'm gonna do a
book tour or more in the UK and that
when I say UK we could do kind of a
thing where it's like a breakfast event
in London and a dinner event or book
signing in Manchester here we got it
like I think what is whatever sells the
most god damn books yeah you have a
target in mind like you coming to a city
like that 1 million books all right okay
let's say like realistically
Alex T Simone has and I think it's like
4,000 books for me to travel somewhere
but obviously if like that means like in
the US if I have to go to like you know
to Chicago and wasn't planning on it
because of all the stuff with our new
office there
yeah we're just maximizing I'll take
8,000 because somebody really wants me
or I'll take you know 2002 spots it's
just a little train hustle so or or
we'll do one in London in the morning as
a breakfast business thing and I might I
mean it's Europe I might hop in a plane
and go to a different country if
somebody watches this on dailyvee and
decides they want me there I think Raj
has a broad enough shoulders to pull it
off I just don't want to [ __ ] him
and want to be really upfront with my
expectations cool all right awesome
bloody bro thanks man it's here care we
do
oh yeah I'm gonna comment out and come
in
you want some let's go do it go dressing
no just get me what the Rastas of my
time and I'll do it you'll be best so
you feel like snapshots gonna work for
you if this is your moment sleepless
hangout less watch less football and
triple attack now triple tap so here's
your league snapshots gonna work for you
I really think this is a moment for
snapchat clearly for a lot of you
debating and like is it because of my
investment or am I hired as a
spokesperson which always very flattered
by I'm pushing because I want to be
historically right like I did on the
askgaryvee show
174 when i expand on this this is just
the moment so going all-in
so cashing in all favors I'm I'm helping
people I'm reaching out to friends that
are big in other areas trying to get
them on because I think they're gonna
win I'm trying to educate my team I'm
using it as much as possible
you know you might post about it once
every seven times and ask for people to
follow you because that's how you get
them from followers instead of every
four times I'm willing to be like
perceived as annoying to some to squeeze
that that orange as much as humanly
possible because I don't want to have
regrets because I know that this is a
moment to land grab on the platform that
is going to dominate the end consumers
attention seems juicy to look good man I
do snapping that too but some guys I am
here in vaynermedia with the one the
only
security yeah what do we recommend
summer they do it good man out of you
good uh I just wanted to jam a little
but I'm in short just seeing I told you
I should I would like to think they give
you context from the meeting we had AJ
says it's imperative that you're in the
meeting do you want to cut um reporting
short by 30 minutes yeah
Hey hi how are you good how are you
really good good
oh hey yes don't worry often will be
edited now you're talking about very
sensible like alright let's get the
conversation cool thank you for the time
I appreciate it
talk to you soon thanks I don't give in
since I really want to wrap up our
communication 16 - good you're charged
because I mean email being like Island
talk about this tweet that got sent okay
so again I'll to speak I change my mind
often that's what yeah you said okay do
I didn't know if you might find some
time right before if you have an idea I
just want to run with it what I didn't
do a good job of it judge that right
hook is to talk about how freewheeling
the right hook should be the right hooks
for you
and survive the pros shitload of right
hooks for the first month of 2016
because I want to build up my
distribution channel and snapchat that's
what I'm gonna do I think that's a whole
other article like the thing I didn't
talk about enough and right now that is
a great idea let's write an article of
like oh by the way one crown right you
know what if we call it round 13 since
most things round 13 other thing I did
it oh yeah click they suck about 13 :
like you know um uh one major
clarification from judge Debra hook I'm
let started with like with my new book
askgaryvee coming it may be hard back to
anything yeah I like because what I
didn't do and obviously everybody's
getting huge for you this is why daily
base can be much I want this whole thing
in this me right like basically immunity
of the whole time is a plus will be fun
for people see how articles get done
yeah they get to see that it is me but
like how we structured right yeah um
it's scary be kind of mean with calm so
there Rebecca and Emily like me Andy
Britney and columns all met together to
talk about ways in which we can make
getting your content syndicated much
more streamlined and efficient
get it indicated more and one of the big
things that we really need to do more is
talk to them about like headlines a lot
of the time and like how we're
positioning an articles so Andy and I
were hoping to get your approval on the
next eight articles that I'm going to
write so and now it's going to be with
the rest of the team by going you first
like real daily via parents in this real
life isn't so sure of the day awesome
yeah yeah you did it
yo Brooklyn we did it okay all right man
we got are you Sue Ellen that's actually
super interesting to me how's the show
even made like because I know like
you're here yeah I mean I I get a good
sense I've been watching sp2 I see you
around the night yeah so that you you
you are we stand for it but it's good
but you know your friends and other
people in the outside yeah I'm just like
is it really exactly so it's like a nice
limb sincere you're like awesome
what's gonna woman no this is always
going on now this is just the way the
world is now make sure like a deal high
cardio um thank you actually just
reached out to that on podiatry sounds
like this is a faster yeah because I had
a very weird day
oh I'm happy now um so I wanted to get
time with you to ask you for some advice
it's good to see you you too
Siri don't edit any of that I want all
her business now hello hi how are you
good it's cooking or the deal fraternity
hatched yet to the High Line it's
amazing like literally attached to it
yeah like and we're moving in right at
that time of year like the like the
first lunch day just like 400 people on
the outside cool pretty soon
stay well fine bye
I really want to be involved yes please
cool thing it's cool but you use me okay
I am yes I work for you
great Congrats dr. Gary yay hi Anna hi
Anna
okay look
Wow all right is that your scooter y'all
you're so cute
you look so much like your mommy Wow
it's a big six-year-old you are now take
multi there's not much Jason yeah to see
if he's gone through okay you know check
it what sue before bring that up to
James all see hey how's going
how was your New Year's on that good
good I feel like the moment though we
haven't had a meeting I definitely feel
like through things I've been
communicating to Andy to prep for seven
sixteen and things of that nature it
seems like there's more momentum of
things to be done and things up meaning
that have been done more recycler having
a better cadence of momentum from the
way I'm auditing you from afar is that
do you see that to be true as well yeah
I feel like there's a lot more just
stuff there's a ton more stuff and I
feel like there's been more donation
like just in general like responsibility
that's right and then I get like okay I
own this isn't this one that's okay now
I can run with that that's right excited
them they'll be more clarity around this
but this is the really uh there's
another reason just to teach them how I
manage there's another reason I like
this you find out how much bandwidth
somebody actually has just hello hi how
are you are you good so um let's pick up
our conversation thanks thank you so
much super super whelming how are you
great house yes great
yeah cool I just wanted to take a couple
minutes and you know start establishing
the communication plan well I'm super
impressed by you
I really like the work you do and I look
for us to know each other better I
almost wet telecom I almost went into
this room because I saw you and I am my
business so we're just a bunch of b-list
snapchat
hey my pleasure as always
nice seriously like great I think I've
been make a 7:30 anywhere 7:30 DC too
far
Connecticut empty see later out
Connecticut Philly New York Jersey who
wants it so anything good from Dallas I
got a couple things bro so we have an
offer for 3,000 right now get the [ __ ]
out of here I have looking this was my
theory on this whole really this is what
we should do we didn't run ads I want
organic I don't even [ __ ] go I went
organic on my facebook post
I didn't even geo it do you really get
this is a bad guys is a wrench to the
whole thing like I kind of just feel
like just being like Chicago who wants
it
Cleveland [ __ ] I honestly would like
so I have a lot more books that I need
this for [ __ ] yeah the only book closes
up like Dallas for coming we got this
opening we don't want to be inefficient
and now I'm 3,000 books sold like that's
super interesting right we can talk more
through that about confident and there
a couple more emails about having to
build a we're gonna do a call to action
for the South the night of March 9th
haha anyway so let's go call to action
to make the design like this is clearly
working yeah I knew it was going to Alex
if we don't hit number one in York Times
bestseller list what are you gonna do
quit no balance this actually very good
thing and I'll say the way that make it
funny and even tastes like a sale you
see something in the comments like you
know like your check like Andrew L users
good example you just want to see how
the image that you made for the thing
and you just see something like I rather
Alex get bored emails from all of you
like hey do you see what Lance said in
the comments then not like let's all be
very vigilant of anything including you
read something in your Twitter stream of
like somebody bought a thousand books
from somebody at like anything that
makes your ears perk up on a sale I
think Brett I think you're gonna have a
lot of opportunity for it let's let's
make sure we focus on that all right
cool thanks guys yes
um all right pixie rock look good
awesome
later David what you thought it was over
do away dinner meetings times - lets go
Phil and I are talking about how wait
why meanings our village in just eight
thirteen meetings is the earliest we've
ever had a visit
absolutely let's start at 10:45 time for
the next meeting